the world has changed
[Music]
I want the world to never forget money
our name
in my opinion you're making the best
cars in the world
but with all my Ferraris there is a
problem the clutch I have a solution if
you consider a partnership Ferrari
Lamborghini
go back to your tractors farmer
what are you thinking thinking of a car
that doesn't exist yet one that is a
strong and powerful and is Unforgettable
as the board
I'm going to build it how long will it
take can't be done if it doesn't work
we'll lose everything you want me to be
like everyone else
it's not impossible until we fan in six
months in Geneva people will be looking
for the next flat eye
what they will find is the first level
that's something new I don't know if
this would work
[Music]
I'll be ready for this one day
why do you think that the world needs
another luxury car it's Perfection that
I am after
thank you
don't care about me the only thing that
matters is a great Lamborghini what do
you want me to do
to make the best cars
tell them what you're doing
[Music]
Lamborghini is too uneducated to
understand what he doesn't know
you buy a Ferrari when you want to be
someone
you buy a Lamborghini when you are
someone
[Music]
what do you see lines on a napkin what
do you see